[音楽]
こんにちは私です
まず最初に私の撮った1枚の写真をご覧いただきたいん
見ていただいております
この写真です
みなさんどんな認証
community 風景から持ちますでしょうか
私はこの風景にすごく感動ししたんですね
まずここにいる人たちが
自由に
一人一人が主役となって
この椅子を使っている
この様子です
このような風景は
これを見た当時の日本ではほとんど
街の中になかったんですね
環境デザインを専門とする私にとってはもう一つ
このような声を
作っている
その概念
にも
凄く感動しました
普通にある
芝生やそれから
小太刀ですね
のちょっと古木に見える木がー
ありますけど
そのような懐を使って
椅子を置いただけそれから小さな建物が
その既存の公園につけたされていますけれどもそれも
飲食物を得る
お店とかそれからパンフやでしたら
せいぜい10たぐらいの規模の小さな季節大げさな施設はありません
この風景から
実は2つの
ことが学べると感じました一つは
こういう形で街を利用する私達の
心持ちですもう一つはこのような公的な
場所を用意する
自治体とかそれからそれを支援する民間企業です
そのような2つのことを
私は日本で
ボールが実現しようと考えましたですがアメリカだからできるんじゃないか
それから
文化が違うんじゃないか
という風に
いろんな声が出てきました
この荒野ニューヨークのマンハッタンの中なのでは確かにそう思われるかもしれません
そこで
このようなよー
見つけました
これは日本の
昔の絵図です江戸時代の
レイズですけども
外で人々が楽しそうに
食べ物を食べながら過ごしていません
ここには先ほどの
公園にあったような
動かせるベンチやそれから動かせる座敷
がたくさん置いております
つまり声を用意した人たちが入ってここに食べ物を用意して綱を楽しんでいた人がいる
ということですよね
これを見たときに日本にも
こうした場を楽しみそれから用意するような関数や文化があったほうがあったという
いう風に
思いました
そこで少し自信を
もっと私は
その後こうした日本の風景や海外の事例を調査したり
それを基にいろんな社会実験をしたり実践をして舞いました
その中で
分かってきたことがあります
それは実はそれほど難しいことではなくて仕事をあたしたちが
身の回りにある
空間や物を使って
結構簡単にできるんだなということです
ですがこれを用意する
自治体の方々が少し面倒なことになるかも知れませ
そこでこの8つのばと名付けた
私の造語が生んでいますけれどもこれを一つずつ
先ほどの公演を事前に説明していきたいとおもいます
まずは座る場所を用意する戸数はリバです
実はこのい数は色は違いますけども
この公園で使われている人同じものです
ご覧のように使う人たちが自分でこれを
都合の良いようにありは好きなように並べて使っています
この例では複数の椅子を使って物を置いたりもしています
そしてここにスターときに足を投げ出したりいろんな形で使うことができます
このようなすわりばと呼んでいる
ばですけどもこれがこの後の7つの場にも
ずっとつながってまいります
ということでこのバワー座ればと言う
バーですね
基本的なばの要素もあります
続いて
これは何でしょうか
そこにあるのはねスターの座席ですねこれは先ほどと同じ公園の中です
主の形状違いますけどもこの座席に座った時に見える風景が
一つの長めになっております
ということでこの公演にはいろんな座席からこれとは違う眺め馬場
見えてまいります
例えば先ほどメールでのように座ったときに自分で
その座席を選ぶわけですけれども普通皆さんどのようにその座席を選ばれるでしょうか
この購入さあという人たちは
観察していきますとやはり自分の居場所を探しながら歩いていて
そして自分が好きなところを選んでいますその先には何らかの眺めが必ずあってそちら
おこう
向くように
椅子をセットしています
そのような形で自分の目の前にある眺め5
意識しながら
自分の居場所を決めていくと思う
次にそのような眺めを決めの時にもう1つ重要な要素があります眺めは自分の前に展開
している
風景ですけれども実は
私たちは動物でもありますのでやっぱり実籾を守る本能があって
人の背後に例えば何らかの法囲う壁ですとか壁それから
植物ですねのようなものがあると安心する
超と思います私のでこの写真のレイドに座ってる人の後ろに
ある植物やそれから池田家のようなものが
一つの過去になりますし頭の上にある樹木もある種の過去
よそになります
次にこのような
写真はちょうどご覧いただけます先ほどの
写真と少しに入っていますけれども
この木から下に落ちてくる影です
私たちは特に日本人は日陰を思います
日向にはあまり触れたくないという人が多いですよねたぶん皆さんもそうだています
そのような人たちのために
木陰が用意されていればこれが翳りばです
この公園も日向はもあるし木陰もあるしそれを自分の好きな方
場所として選んでいきます
特に木陰というのは日の光によって
時間によって変わってきますですので今ここに陽があたってますけども
しか日陰を好み首都はそこから
少し濃い通して影に座って側に言うということが
心地よい関係を付ける重要なポイントになります
そして二木です
そのような
あいくつかの心地よい場所を作る要素がその度に
もう一つ何か欲しいものが
ありますよそれは食べ物です
この写真では飲み物やそれが食べ物それぞれが持ち寄ってきています
この公演の中には先ほど言いましたようにいろんなレストランやカフェなどがあるので
そこでテイクアウトも買おう
そのように用意された食べもそれから持ち込む食べ物を自由に自分で組み合わせて
このように
過ごすことができます一人でもちろん食べてもいいし
何人かで食べることもできます
何人かで集まった時は必ずそこに加山が発生します
そしてこの写真のみろ
ここでご覧いただいたように
そこに話ば話を進みましょうそれからもちろんそこには話すと同時に聞くという行為も
出てきますけども
それを
私は話毎読ません
そしてこの話早座りばそして
いろんな眺めも含めて実は昼間だけでなく夜も
こういった街中に滞在したくなる
ことがわかりますその時に
ただ単に街灯があるだけだと寒々しくていっ
あまりそういう気になりませんけどこのように飲食店があったり
それがお店があって
その明かりが外に漏れている
このような状態だとこの写真のようにその周辺に座っていただくもなります
これを灯りばと呼んでいます
このようないくつかの様子がたくさん
その場所この場合公園ですけども
s そこでは
この方のように入っ数を持って違う場所に移動したり
術からその移動先で座って
また少し時間を
そこで過ごすよ
そういった行動が発生しています
ですのでその公演自体が一つのめぐりー
場になってくる
それをめぐりばと呼んでいます
最後にもう一度全体の議論
みてください
このような1つの
公園という空間の中にいくつかの
基本となるばが
見てております先ほど申し上げたばですねそれを支える樹木とか
平らな地面そして芝生これはもともとあったものです
9公演の姿というのはもともとあったものにこうした軽いものどこへでもあるものを
組み合わせただけなんですよ
でもそれをやって復号化したいろんなば
用意されてそれを使う人たちが
講師役のように使っているということですそれを
それを実は今日みなさまにあなーむ
お話ししようと思って困りました
いろんなその
自治体の方々はこういった公園ありは公共的な空間を用意しているしております
それは人は
私たちはこのような使い方をしてくれると大変
町が3足的になって良いことになります
それから民間企業にとっても
そこで光響曲がを支援して
あけど商売をしたりそも
に植物サービスしたりすることによって
そこでは利潤を得ながら地域貢献をすることもできます
双方が
そういう形で
支援し合ってさらにこう使う私たちが楽しく自由に
そして主体的に主役のようにこの公園を使ってくることで街の風景が変わってきます
ですのでただ単に用意するところそれからサービスするところがあってもこのような
バーは成長していきません
私たちが使ってこそそれが成長していきます
このような場の釣り方は実は
私たちの自分の家やそれから職場にも活かすことができます
ですのでここにいらっしゃる皆さんがおそらく
今でもすぐできますし今後いろんな
例えば民間企業は公的機関に就職したとしてあるいは家に
入って仕事をする場合もそれぞれの
自分の場所を自分で作りあるいは自分で洗濯しそこに置くものを選択して自分の場を
作っていきます
そうすると
皆さんにとってデートスポット
やり方とかもう買ってくるかもしれませんしそれぞれの立場で
いろんな場を職場に作ったり
有安の公的な場にすることを支援したいというようなことを
専門家でなくてもできるようになります
そうで環境デザインを志す私としては
普通に使う人たちそれから全ての人達が
参加してくることが重要ですまちづくりの参加っていうのは結構難しいことのように
思いますけども
街にあるこういうようなその異性が用意された
ところに行ったらそこに座ってくれるだけでも街の風景に参加して参加していることも
あります
っていうことはそこに皆さんがまちづくりに貢献していることです
それから先ほど言ったようにいろんな
zusso 総理の立場でですねそのような場づくりを
あるいはそういう条件を作るといったりは仕事を少しでもしてくれることによって
私たちの住環境はすごくよくなっていきます
なので
この場を通じて皆さま方にそういう場づくりへの参加を是非
期待しております
以上ですとがとうございましたと
[拍手]